in this morning's ion money many
Americans are being left behind when it
comes to saving for retirement listen to
this almost half of people 55 and older
have saved nothing CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here with
how you can catch up financially now you
would think those people I can call them
those people because I am one of those
people you would think they would know
better what happened well I think
there's a couple of things first of all
remember we used to have a system where
people would say I get my Social
Security I have a pension right I work
for a company and I have my own savings
we then saw a shift from pensions where
your company paid for your retirement
right to you paying for your retirement
to the 401k era and you know when we put
that burden on workers it's really a lot
harder also when you have a 401 K or a
403 B those kinds of accounts they are
incredibly susceptible to downturns when
you have a pension the company's got to
put more money in during a downturn
right when you're on the downturn you're
like oh my god I got to get the money
out of my retirement account I got to
pay my bills that combination has put so
many Americans behind the 8-ball so what
to do well I think that what to do is if
you have a plan through your employer we
know that participation is the key and
although a lot of people don't have
those employment employer plants a lot
of people are opting out of them so stay
in it put a teeny tiny piece aside 1% of
your salary 2% if you don't have an
employer plan
unfortunately it's harder you've got
open up your own IRA account of your own
Roth IRA account many banks and
financial institutions make this a lot
easier and whatever you do you want to
automate it I automatically had some
money come out of that feel it exactly
how about you coming out of your savings
or checking go into that account good
news here for investors and people
saving for retirement costs have come
down dramatically
alright did you ever take out of your
401 it's a last measure so we have when
you talk about lending from a 401 K a
lot of people feel like okay that's my
money I want to get it yeah I want
people to think twice about it and
here's why when you have a 401 k loan
the money comes out of your paycheck to
pay yourself back but if you leave that
company whether on your own or because
someone laid you off you've got to pay
that money back before tax time and boy
back in me
penalty's it can mean taxable
distribution and it could be dangerous
you're never taking out of that
retirement because you want to
exactly exactly that's Joe thank you
very much